apparently there's something going down
in afghanistan i don't know uh people
have been talking about it a lot so we
figured why not talk to a journalist
who's actually on the ground okay we've
got boots on the ground or sandals maybe
in your case
we have with us
journalist scholar
um and verified twitter account the only
reason i replied
uh ali latifi
okay who is in kabul right now he is in
kabul right now uh he is he's looking at
our set the only thing he commented on
was the gold ak-47 so you know [ __ ] is
going down
in afghanistan somehow he's smiling um
and he is he is cheerful and he looks
like an afghan george lopez welcome to
the show
uh welcome to the show so obviously we
have so many questions please tell us
just right now you are
uh
you were born and raised in kabul
correct i was born in kabul i was raised
in california okay so you're born in
kabul raised in california we have so
many questions but i just want to start
breaking this down please give us an
understanding
of
what
life was like
under u.s occupation and then yeah what
has changed in the last couple days so
again everybody listening right now he
is in kabul afghanistan the taliban have
just taken control of pretty much the
entire country they have taken control
of kabul they are operating and
controlling uh the media any military
forces and everything that's going on so
one what was life like you during u.s
occupation
um
it's okay it's it's a country of of of
like
and i know it's kind of a cliche but
it's a country of like really really
large contrasts right yeah so
you know you you will see a fancy
high-rise building you know there's one
across from me that has a dome on it
that looks like the us capital
um you know there's a new steakhouse and
like sports lounge that opened up only
less than a year ago
that they both cost like two million
dollars to build
but then at the same time on the way
there you see homeless heroin addicts
you know just just on the street
um or
when
like in the winter when it rains
you know i live in like the downtown
commercial area above these two big
banks
but when it rains unless a car like
literally backs up into the entrance of
the building i can't get out because the
water will be up to my knees
um
so so it's it it it's very
there has been a lot of change and a lot
of advancement obviously since the
taliban but also that doesn't mean
anything right because the taliban came
to power
in 1996 after a civil war and before
that was the soviet occupation so
everything was destroyed so when in 2001
when the u.s started their occupation
um
there was nothing it was it was
literally zero right so if you go from
zero to one or zero to ten
or even zero to like 30 or 40 it's still
a huge improvement you know right right
um
and so
[Music]
that's really what it was like because
you know you would go places where
the nearest hospital was like 40
kilometers down an unpaved road right
you know uphill
um so if you were poor what would you do
right or whether your school was like
that
um
so there were rich people there they
were living good lives they were eating
at steak houses etc but they're
incredibly poor people as well so that
discrepancy and wealth is is very
difficult i think most americans right
now are watching what's happening and
they're going how the [ __ ]
can a terrorist organization because
that's how we see the taliban right we
just we hear taliman and we're like oh
it's no different than isis no different
than al-qaeda like we think they're all
synonymous right and uh so forgive our
ignorance if we don't understand if
there's more of a political motive there
what's going on but how can a terrorist
organization right of a bunch of dudes
right just
it seems like running around on the back
of toyota tacomas take over an entire
country in a few days can you explain
how that happened
and if that is what happened
it happens
because of poor planning
from the u.s side
and the avalon side it happens from
corruption on the u.s side and the
avalon side it happens because of a
really smart astute taliban that took
advantage of a situation
it happens because of
a peace deal that trump signed with them
that emboldened them and made them feel
i mean they were victorious but it
solidified their idea of victory what
was the peace deal that trump signed
so in 2020 on on february 29th 2020
uh doc
black history month leap year
uh donald trump they can leap a sign
signed a peace agreement
with the taliban that basically said
they were supposed to leave
in may of this year very much
the u.s right sorry the u.s was supposed
to leave in may of this year and part of
the agreement was that
in exchange for that agreement the
taliban would not attack u.s or foreign
soldiers or targets of any kind
and that
the us would agree to draw down their
forces to a hundred percent
and allow
push for the taliban to have five
thousand of their prisoners released
um
so that was it was
it it you know like the taliban let's be
honest we're already winning military
militarily even before that
but this just
this was like the icing on the cake you
know this this this set it for them and
they were like look we got an agreement
from the us you know i mean it's you
know we've been asking
it seems to me that agreement is just
here's the key is it's your country now
that's exactly that's that
because then then then you know they
were meeting with other countries in the
past because in 2011
obama approved for them to go to doha to
have like a political office right where
they were supposed to discuss peace
and ever since they first got there they
were having like secret meetings with
westerners and with regional countries
and
um
europeans and all of this but
uh
it wasn't like it was never like you
know fully
formal and recognized and and uh you
know made public you know it was still
very hush-hush right yeah after the
peace deal the taliban went on a world
tour yeah they were they were emboldened
yeah and they were everywhere and they
and they were going on this diplomatic
mission and assuring different countries
that when we come to power
like they told china you don't have to
worry about the uyghurs we won't even
though they can consider themselves to
be an islamic movement
they turn their back on the uyghurs you
know
they told tajikistan and uzbekistan like
you know we won't
let these armed groups from your country
into our country
they told russia you don't have to worry
about those central asian armed groups
you don't have to worry about
daesh or isis so they made all these
deals with all these other countries and
so all these other countries are
supporting them
uh becoming the the the the rainbow
power the ruling party because it's
beneficial for these other countries ah
so the way the media is portraying this
back home is that the taliban like just
completely rinsed
the afghan national forces at a f it's
called a nsf all right guys we're gonna
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because i gotta tell you about the
best bong in the business the best way
to smoke your weed your cbd
[ __ ] i don't even know if people are
smoking tobacco out of bongs but if you
want to do it you could do it and that's
with freeze pipe okay there are two
types of cannabis smokers out there
those who suffer from burning scratchy
throats and those who smoke a free spike
with freeze pipes freezable glycerin
coils you'll enjoy the colder bigger
hits without the throat burning or
intense coughing today right here i'm
holding their king of cold and newly
released the freeze pipe bong duel with
two levels of water filtration and their
largest glycerin coil this thing is like
taking bong rips from mr freeze's ice
gun the secret is freezable glycerin
chambers that cool smoke by hundreds of
degrees okay for smoother and bigger
hits when you smoke the smoke passes
through these frozen chambers and it's
instantly cooled for a much nicer hit
you'll feel it instantly your throat and
lungs will thank you trust me on this
check out this bong or freeze pipes
entire line of unique pipes bubblers
bombs and dab breaks at the
freezepipe.com use the promo code
flagrant and save 15 off your first
order go to the
freezepipe.com that's
www.thefreezepipe.com
to get yours today and use the code
flagrant and save 15 off your first
order okay remember you go to
thefreezepipe.com
thefreezepipe.com to get yours today use
the code flagrant you save 15 off your
first order now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip that you can find
the whole episode at patreon.com
the afghan national forces at a f it's
called
a nsf and sf right and but in reality
there was no pushback in reality this
was the agreement
it was once america's out of here we're
taking over and everybody knew that so
we're pretending
as if there was some war going on the
last few days when it's all [ __ ]
everybody knew exactly what's going to
happen
part of it know i mean there was a war
and there was a push back but the
pushback came from
security forces that had already
been suffering for so long and didn't
have the support that they needed you
know i've been saying this everywhere
i've been reporting on this since 2011
i've been going to the provinces i've
been meeting with people i remember
meeting police and soldiers who had to
buy their own boots you know i remember
talking to police and soldiers who said
they didn't have food to eat who hadn't
been paid in months and some of the most
dangerous provinces in the country
you know and then also they're serving
areas where there really isn't
necessarily much development or
advancement
and you know like there were cases where
soldiers would die and their family
would have to go and get the dead bodies
somehow and either bring them on the
back of a taxi or get one of the private
airlines to allow them to charter it for
free so
loyalty
to
the ans a and sf because the answer the
government the government the government
was super corrupt right right so
they weren't getting you know like they
were asking for weapons they weren't
getting it they were asking for support
and backup when they came under attack
they weren't getting there were
instances before in the past when
district provinces were about to fall
but the people around the president were
lying to him and saying like oh no it's
not that bad
and only when it when it was teetering
on the edge did he find out the truth
and then do something
uh let me ask you a question real quick
you talked about how
um there was a lot of corruption and the
us writing in a speech yesterday said
they were funding the afghan military
what was happening to the money do you
have any idea obviously they didn't get
it there was corruption where was it
going do we know
contractors contractors and
subcontractors right because everything
was contracted out
uh
to all you know like people within the
ministry of defense and within the
ministry of interior were corrupt
you know they from the top were skimming
they were making deals with their
friends and getting cuts themselves
you know and and finding like the
cheapest sort of alternatives or the
easiest alternatives like there was
investigation
so there's a u.s
body called the sigar the special
investigator general
for afghanistan reconstruction and they
they basically have for the last almost
decade have just been uh going and
just evaluating all of the spending in
the us and they found that they spent
something like tens of millions of
dollars
on camouflage uniforms that do not suit
the afghanistan environment at all
do you know what i'm saying they're made
for like a jungle scenario or something
yeah like for vietnam left over in the
70s yeah yeah like vietnam or the amazon
or something so this is interesting so
there's all this corruption that exists
within the regime and power that the us
is backing and because of that
connection the people of afghanistan
don't feel any loyalty
right yeah very little there or they
feel very little loyalty so they're like
i'm not gonna risk my life fighting for
these people that aren't even taking
care of us especially if they're out of
here and i'm no longer gonna be getting
paid like it's one thing if you're
getting stipends you're getting food
they're keeping you alive but if the u.s
and the
the people that are essentially backing
down sf are saying we're out of here
then they're like what the [ __ ] am i
fighting for
and at the same time you had taliban
showing up to these districts with
pictures of them standing next to like
foreign officials including the u.s
officials and saying well you know we're
going to get the country in a few weeks
anyways and they already promised us
this district so you might as well just
lay down
so they're going to these places these
are like remote villages they're not
having access to the internet they're
not watching [ __ ] exactly and they
see a picture of the taliban guy next to
jiji ping or the taliban guy next to
like the british crime or something like
that and they're like oh i guess the
taliban is ruling we don't even need a
fight we're just going to walk over this
is fascinating none of this is being
reported over here by the way yeah when
you said that we were losing over there
essentially the taliban like was winning
militarily in my mind i was like really
i always thought we were kicking the
[ __ ] out of these people over there and
they were just kind of like scattered
and
if you were kicking the [ __ ] out of them
if if you were kicking the [ __ ] out of
them there would be no reason for the us
to have this visa fiasco where they set
up these visas to get interpreters who
worked with the us military out and then
later journalists and prominent women
and human rights workers and all of that
which
i kind of have to say is
like that whole program was a lot of
[ __ ] yeah yeah
you know like it was just super
convoluted it didn't make any sense you
know people couldn't get to undergo
direct contact like i imagined it would
be like a portal or something right like
remember when you used to apply to
university like there was a website
where you submitted all your documents
and you
went through all this bs you know just
just i thought it would be something
it's nothing like it's just like a
website that says do this do this do
this but it doesn't tell you how to do
it and it doesn't specifically tell you
who to get in contact with or how to ask
questions
there was nothing like that
right and then you had people who you
know let's say they worked with the us
10 years ago or five years ago and they
have to find a us citizen like the
highest ranking u.s citizen they were in
contact with to vouch for them and so
when they would find these people
they would be like yo i haven't worked
for these people
in years i don't even know if i have the
authority plus i don't know who i'm
supposed to send this letter to
or how i'm supposed to do it so there's
nothing clear about this and at the same
time like i said like if they were
kicking the [ __ ] out of the taliban then
why did you need to make these my
parents wouldn't be so mad i'm cussing
like why why did you need to make these
these stupid visas that you know like
right essentially left thousands of
people stranded in the end and gave them
false hopes right what up people you
just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace